what is multi-access edge computing how
is it different than regular edge
computing
hi i'm dan keen from ibm cloud and
before i answer those questions
please click like and subscribe edge
computing
is about bringing compute capacity
closer where data is created to reduce
response time and the load on backend
servers
multi-access edge computing is the next
logical step
in edge computing for telco cloud it
brings compute capacity directly to
network's edge
literally on the same infrastructure as
the network itself
let's go through it using an example so
we have
say an image application that does image
analysis
it communicates with the core network
that in turn works with the backend
server
for sake of discussion on that back-end
server let's assume we have
service called image analysis service
installed
okay this is a classical application
design pattern
the user makes a request it goes to a
back-end server
it formulates a response that returns
the end user a round trip for that
including latency might be on the order
of 100 milliseconds
that's perfectly fine for many
applications but let's assume we have a
more demanding application
for example one that does video
and it isn't using just one user
that it wants to capture it's capturing
a crowd
maybe it's used for security purposes
maybe it's used for threat analysis so
there's just some examples
what really drives us towards an edge
computing solution
are two things first there's a lot of
data
now an hd video camera that could stream
as much as six megabits per second
the other thing is the real time aspect
we need a real-time response
it would be difficult to send all that
data back to the backend server
process it and return it in real time
that's why we install
edge servers closer to where the source
of data is
so say for example we install some edge
servers
and on those we install the video
analysis service
this really helps with our latency
problem we no longer have to send data
across the network
to a far away server it also helps with
our data value problem
we're no longer sending huge amounts of
data across the network
where multi-access edge computing comes
into play
is when we add a third element
specifically mobility
in the prior examples we were assuming
that these edge computers were in a
fixed location
for example at a retail location
providing a shopping experience
maybe an iot device and a factory that's
doing
assembly those are examples where the
edge computer location is known
in this case for multi-axis edge
computing
it could be anywhere we cannot predict
where the edge computers might be
located so we install them on the
network
itself so for example we have a radio
access network and then install it
at the base station or
we could install it at the data center
for the network itself
this really drives latency to its
absolute minimum
as little as 10 milliseconds it also
reduces the load on the back-end server
for the enterprise
we could then repurpose that for
something else for example we could do
machine learning
so for example say we do machine
learning training
then we take that result and we give it
to the video analysis service
to improve the quality of its results
there's a couple other different
benefits that are worth noting
because this is running on the network's
infrastructure
if there is a temporary outage between
the
backend server and video analysis it can
continue to process
thus you have continuous operations
finally there is the ability to take
advantage of
radio access network data
for example the radio access network
would know where the location of the
users are
and it could potentially predict where
additional load would be required
this allows their network to be much
more responsive to users needs
and being able to deploy capacity where
it's going to be needed in the future
multi-access edge computing means
communication service providers can
bring compute capacity directly to your
users
no matter where or how they connect to
the network
thank you for watching if you have
questions please drop us a line below
if you want to see more videos like this
in the future please like and subscribe